une canne elle plus une barre chocolatée
plus une sucette à 2 euros c'est une
marge du futur même en chine sont partis
ça en tout cas si on vous donne la
petite brochure contre le racisme le
sourire en ce moment ça mandin compris
ça fait deux fois qu'on fait ah oui avec
sfr tir nantais j'aimerais bien savoir
toi bats comme tout
le mec avait car le gars ont bossé pour
toi je crois paulhan pourquoi t'as du
clitoris
j'aime bien chanter course au jeu peu
frais qu'elle ait reçu par marché il
faut oser est riche de visualisation est
à plaindre à quoi on a juste se poser si
je faisais là dessus la viande puis il
ya plusieurs noms de plus quand tu perds
poule d'artois comm sa
je sais même pas comment tu t'appelles
ouais c'est con mais quand tu es tu
des responsabilités
aimer c'est comme des chiens se sentent
que tu as tort ils te bouffe peut-être a
souvent l'air d'avoir coeur mon japon
vers toi t'as pas tes tripes en tout six
ans j'aime beaucoup
baroud et